[Music]
that's texans running back mark ingram
earlier this week that was not a deep
fake video he said what he said
miles posts a story at pft which is what
we do
athletes say things that are interesting
and we post them and tweet them and mark
ingram
responds saying i see miles was bored
today laughter your cry emoji shrug
emoji so i just think i love mark ingram
i think he's just having some fun i mean
the bottom line is he said what he said
and you know another running back who's
been around for a while who who believes
in himself i got nothing wrong with
confidence you got to have confidence or
you got no business going out onto that
field and risking your life and limb in
in a violent sport like football and
he's got that confidence he can still do
it miles
i'm glad that it seems that he took uh
that article in stride you know because
it's not like he seemed like he wanted
to come after me like oh myles was born
today i wouldn't say that i was bored i
would say that i was just doing my job
sir it's not like you didn't say it so
there but nice kitchen by the way since
we got to see that in the zoo
and i think i think he he meant it in
good fun
based on the time i've been around him
and dealt with him i i don't think he
was if he if he had a hostile message
for you the hostility would have been
far more obvious than what we saw in
that tweet all right other other tweets
we have seen today as we ask for
questions that we can try to answer
keywords try
at fied 2 do you think michael thomas is
going to have a bounce back year miles
remember in 2019 it was 149 catches
single season record last year had that
badly sprained ankle in garbage time of
week one win over the buccaneers and
then there was issues with a paid
suspension and
chatter about possibly being traded his
agents were trying to stir up interest
in someone to trade for him that is a
fact do you think he bounces back this
year
i think it depends on who his
quarterback is because if it's taysom
hill
i'm not confident that that offense is
going to resemble anything that we
really saw with drew brees i think it's
going to be more run heavy i think that
you know they're going to probably do
things on the inside a little bit more
and i know that michael thomas has done
a great job of catching things closer to
the line of scrimmage and then getting
yards after the catch but like
i don't know man if jameis winston is
the quarterback i would feel a lot
better about it because i think that
jameis winston has shown a much better
penchant for being a quarterback who
throws than taysom hill i think he's a
quarterback who runs and happens to
throw when he needs to but yeah i i sort
of anticipate jameis winston will be the
quarterback but because we don't know i
feel like it's hard to answer that
question
yeah i think you're right it all depends
upon what the offense is going to look
like which depends on which guy is the
quarterback now there's no reason to
think michael thomas is going to be
injured all year again but he's going to
feel the pressure
and i think it's actually it's better
than last year because last year he goes
into the season he wants to do more than
149 well it was hard enough to get to
149. just just enjoy that you got the
149 you can get to 150. and even with an
extra game this year don't worry about
how many balls you catch worry about a
team that maybe can be
better offensively at stretching the
field forcing defenses to defend all of
the field
and if that can open up the offense it
may be easier for michael thomas to not
just catch you know 10-yard pass but
maybe get the ball in his hands and do
more damage with and have more yards and
more touchdowns and forget about the
number of catches jay carm will julian
edelman be on the patriots week one
roster is he sneaky cut candidate his
dead cap hit wouldn't be that bad uh i'm
not sure that physically julian edelman
is good to go with that knee problem and
and i also can't help but wonder miles
at some level whether or not he's
feeling like a bat signal to tampa to
join gronk and tom brady down there for
another championship run
and uh
not that they need him but i'm sure tom
brady would love to have him around if
he could get him that that one has just
kind of been lurking as a possibility
for me but it just feels like julian
edelman is getting dangerously close to
the end of the road
yeah and i think the injury situation is
probably more concerning than you know a
cut situation because he has a salary
and then the dead cap isn't that much i
also totally agree with you on the whole
bat signal to tampa bay thing like i
think that clearly they pro they don't
need him you know we were just talking
about how they don't really need antonio
brown but if you have somebody like
julian edelman who has the built-in
chemistry already with tom brady and has
you know that experience of winning
championships i think that it makes
sense for him to try to get one last
ride with brady if he can um they
obviously let gronkowski do that last
year when they traded in because gronk
was still under contract when he retired
would the patriots love to do that
probably not but you know if tampa bay
is like hey you know we'll give you a
fifth round pick or something for julian
edelman then i think the patriots might
be able to be convinced to do that
one more before we take a quick break
mike defends uk with the possibility of
five quarterbacks going early in the
first round is it the quarterbacks who
are getting more talented or is playing
the position getting easier miles let me
try this one very concisely i don't
think it's either i think it's that
coaches are letting
great college quarterbacks do at the nfl
level what they did at the college level
they're not dramatically changing the
offense and also i i just think the fact
that so many great quarterbacks are
making their way into college they're
getting so many reps in seven on seven
camps it's easier to scout the
quarterbacks it's not as much of a roll
of the dice as it used to be in finding
guys who can come in and play and i
think the teams are doing a better job
of separating the best of the best from
the guys who were just okay
it's easier to train the quarterbacks
because these guys who are qbs they are
built to be qbs of the future from a
very young age i think that when they
start going to these camps that's when
they really start seeing it and then
when they finally get to the league it's
like you know
i'm sorry i did it again i don't know
what they found
i don't know what you're talking about
yeah exactly i know it's a pretty good
book i've heard uh but when they finally
get to the league then that's when
they're able to really show what they
can do and guys know already that they
have a lot of talent so i think the
other part of it is just the contract
situations and how
teams have to get this quarterback right
really quickly because otherwise they're
going to be replaced in the regimes
whether it's the head coach or the
general manager you basically have three
years to prove that you've got your
quarterback right and if you can't do it
within that time frame then they're
going to move on so i think that that
kind of priority that you have to place
on the qb position means that you need
to draft one that you believe in it's
easier to do that if you get there early
you